all right ruby
yes ruby uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm from dallas
texas i'm born and raised
you had mom and dad when you were
growing up um my mom my dad was in iran
um
i mean we were three and persian iranian
and mexican and so
my dad stayed in uh
iran and my mom raised me in a dallas
texas for herself
how would you describe your childhood
different
you know my mom was an actress and so
she suffered uh
mental health issues and um she
actually raised me as a girl um gave me
a girl government name everything you
know she
played a role where she was pregnant and
some um
soap opera in mexico
and she actually gave me the same name
as the character that she you know she
was pregnant with and everything so your
actual given name is uh alexandria
jasmine marquez oh wow
so your mom raised you as a girl my mom
raised me as a girl from infant you know
baby i got baby pictures i got you know
elementary school pictures you know me
you know in a dress with the matching
you know
hat
how did that affect you as a
um confused you know i was confused but
um in the mexican uh
home you know like you don't we're
taught as kids that you're not supposed
to like question your parents whatever
they ask you to do even if they're
asking you to jump off a bridge you got
to do it you know you don't you know you
don't ask questions you just
follow directions i guess you know
and did that affect like the way you
were raised like in high school um a
little bit was it difficult um it was
it was kind of
it was kind of perplexing for me you
know because um there's a lot of
pressure being a girl you know a lot of
things that um
that are
you know little things uh the design of
a
of i guess raising a girl and the things
that you know that are important
you know it's just completely different
to you know guys or you know just a
normal you know
male
i guess uh growing up
it's just crazy you know yeah
and how far did you go to school i went
all the way to college yeah people from
elementary school middle school high
school and college students they don't
even know that i was even a guy you know
is that right yep cheerleader prom queen
all of that
and when you were in like
gym class you went to dress out in this
in the women's sudden women's house what
about the locker room uh females yeah
but at some point
at some point that becomes a problem no
no i was always you know like i was like
that was my mom always prepped me you
know like she gave me little you know
tips to prep myself before
you know even like i started hormone um
blockers when i was like from nine to
eight
so i wouldn't hit puberty from the age
of ten
like the gym teacher
i didn't know no nothing you know and
you would keep it private in the locker
room i'd always be like at the far
corner
at the end or i'd be on the other side
you know wow but i'd always come like
you know i'd say i'd always take a
shower at home or something you know oh
i see right
and then since since you're at home or
in college where did your life go to set
um after that
so i grew up in dallas texas and
when i was 15 6 or no 14 we moved to new
mexico and i went out there and that's
where i went to high school finish high
school and i went to college out there
to university i went to new mexico state
university and went to
high school in las cruces high school so
you never really you probably didn't
have a whole lot of problems
no fitting in and blending in yeah like
you were female yeah nobody nobody ever
questioned me not not until now now now
my older years they start saying are you
transgender but back in the day you know
because uh yeah here in la they're more
savvy they're more emerging well they're
doing it yeah because this is it's uh
you see it more often you know you're
able to recognize it when you when you
when you see [ __ ] everywhere all
over la you know you kind of can tell
the difference between especially the
women out here you know they're
beautiful you know so are the
transgenders but you know yeah the
transgender transgenders are sometimes
they put much more effort
and they become more beautiful
yeah it's just you know i guess it's all
just a like uh
with your mind things like my mom when i
was like six or seven she starts telling
me to look in the mirror and say if i
believe that i'm a woman the world would
see a woman so subconsciously she was
teaching me something that was you know
more than uh she was teaching me like
the art of illusion i guess you know do
you feel like you weren't even given a
choice um no and i used to i used to
question it all the time like i was very
suicidal from like 11 to 13 you know
and uh i was because i i wanted to be a
boy you know i told her that she robbed
me from that you know you wanted to be a
boy i wanted to be a boy you know just
because it's so much pressure you know
being a girl um how to go to birthday
parties and i'd go to um i was a pageant
baby so like she she had me go to
birthday parties i was in latino cake i
couldn't play in the in the in the in
the play area i couldn't you know she
didn't want me to start up get bruises
like i was i had a very you know she was
very strict and disciplined but you know
towards the end now that i see it i i
love it i love it because she gave me
self-control she gave me self-discipline
you know in a lot of ways
but um
at the time it's it's not fun it's not
fun you know being able to go to a
birthday party everybody's eating cake
and i couldn't you know because
she had me on a diet it was crazy wow
because you're in pageants yeah pageants
i did a lot of modeling like from 13
until i was 21 i was you know i flew out
to paris everything from my first you
know
my first really big big big
photo shoot was i was 13 we went to
paris and there was a nude you know
with other women and it was just you
know crazy because
i i just didn't feel confident you know
i didn't feel i didn't
i didn't feel like i i looked like these
other girls but you know it worked it
worked you know the look that i had at
the time
so today you're living where i live
right down the street um right here in
the sro called the eugene
right here in skid row
and how long you've been there i've been
here seven years now before here i was
in hollywood and then
but i was homeless in hollywood you know
i was
for uh
and being
homeless and transgender
it's hard you know it's gonna be hard
right yeah because you know we're not
real women so we need a we need a
bathroom we need to shave we need to you
know certain little things that you know
that um
but i mean if you if you're if you do
your transition correctly you don't have
to worry about these things you know
hormone therapy
you know go getting lasik and you know
just being
you know
it's crazy how out here um
you know it's like they purposely keep
transgenders with addictions or they
keep them with um
uh uh some kind of defect because if it
if a transgender was sober and you were
to put any mission in front of a
transgender they would kill it every
time
they would execute it you know
but
it's easier for them to keep attorney
in an addiction so they're not able to
progress because you know they fear that
they fear that if you ever met a
transgender who's sober
they got money they're rich everything
that they want they they manifest it
because they're that powerful you know
but
a lot of [ __ ] you know that's
including myself you know we battle with
drug addiction we battle with them
uh it goes deeper than that you know
it's just all the injustices that we go
throughout throughout the day you know
or just you know
simple little comments you know just
since we put ourselves um on front line
to be criticized be the joke to be you
know
but like i feel like we got more you
know we got more balls in the real man
you know i'm sitting here
going to the world wearing a girl's
outfit and a wig
with my head held up it makes you tough
right
what is your drug um crystal meth and
weed christian yeah
i i kind of slowed down a lot a lot on
the crystal just because um
you know a lot of my friends are dying
you know and um right now it's just this
fentanyl epidemic is crazy you know
everybody's dying from fentanyl but no
and they got it looking like crystal so
it's kind of like that and i lost um
like one of my sons to it over here so
it's crazy
you know and what how do you since
you've been homeless how do you support
yourself oh well i'm i'm not homeless
now but um when i did i was i was you
know i was selling drugs at first
here skid row i was in front of the
mission selling heroin for like a lot
like
i want to say seven years and i was i
was linked up with um 18th street at the
time you know that's who had me working
and then i went to prison got out and
then once i got out of prison i became
very um
how do you say i'm very scared you know
like um so i wouldn't steal i wouldn't
do any of the things that i used to do
whenever i'm paranoid
and so like i just i went to a program i
went and i got this sro and i've been
you know doing that ever since
trying to just have some kind of you
know
change you know because i didn't
a lot of a lot of transgender women will
do sex work to support themselves yeah
and um even occasionally now like i'll
sit there you know whenever i need to
pay a bill or i don't have you know
because i'm living off of gr and food
stamps like sometimes i want to get my
nails done and my feet done so
i know there's a guaranteed it's not
that far you know right here fashion
district is you know the area for for us
you know so
it's crazy that um that i live like
right down the track too because it's
just like um whenever i want to make
some money that's what i go you know
i make what i need to make but i don't
you know i don't ever abuse i just go
just to get what i need and i get out
you know
because no bad experiences doing that
um
yeah uh that's got to be dangerous i've
got kidnapped i've got raped i've got um
held hostages i've heard it awesome you
know the same thing from every girl that
does it yeah and it's crazy because you
would think that you know because we're
not women but it's just like um
i feel for the ones that are feminine
the ones that are passable you know like
especially um if they don't if they're
not you know if they're petite or
whatever you know like they really do
you know and i'm a victim of that where
you know i can't i can't fight with you
know estrogen when you take estrogen it
breaks down all the muscle and all over
your body so
you have you know everything is soft you
have no strength you actually get weaker
when you take hormones you know so it's
just like that strength it gets as is
it's
not like a woman but just quite quite as
much you know
the same you know disabilities and
weaknesses you know
what uh what emotions do you go through
um i go through
a thousand emotions throughout the day i
can be in a good mood or you know and
walk into a store and um sometimes
women especially from i get a lot from
women is um
sometimes they don't know that i'm
transgender and so they'll just see
somebody who's attractive and
automatically
it'll be that and then i'll be like oh
i'm somebody's son you know you
shouldn't feel like that you're where i
want to be and
it's just like it's like i made it worse
for myself because now they're just you
know like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that you
know get him out of here get him at the
store
you know from other from other women you
get huh from other women you'll get this
uh like a majority of them you know out
here in l.a it's all about face value
i've noticed like if you're pretty or if
you're attractive or you're good-looking
you know you get vip
and you know you can tell the difference
you know they always treat attractive
people way better than you know the
average person or
so i hear you know that's one thing that
i hate is just like um depending how you
look is how you know you get served you
know yeah and what about your love life
do you have
um
nobody right now you know um that guy
was just somebody i had just met you
know but um other than that i just a
relationship isn't for me
every relationship i've been with has
been abusive you know and it's just
because i'm somebody who's um
too self-sufficient you know even in a
relationship i don't
i don't feel that i need the help you
know or i don't need you know
if he can bring what he brings it that's
that's his problem you know i just i
always take care of me and it's always
an issue you know
so ruby what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life um maturity i'm going to say you
know um to always be mature you know in
every situation you know
to take it on mid with a little bit of
maturity because
you got to be the bigger person got to
be the adult in a lot of well at least
it's in my life you know because i get
put on you know so many different
situations where
you know i should stand up for myself
but it's not going to help any situation
you know
so i have to be mature you know and just
be like okay well i'ma walk away don't
say nothing just keep walking you know
all right
all right ruby thank you so much for
sharing your story i wish you the best
of luck thank you thank you
you